ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen die
russische Armee hat ihren Angriffskrieg
in den Osten und Süden der Ukraine
verlagert das war seit Tagen befürchtet
worden die Stadt mariopol ist weiter
hart umkämpft und auch was anderen
Gebieten wären heftige Kämpfe gemeldet
die Forderung schwere Waffen zu liefern
auch hier aus Deutschland in die Ukraine
die wird immer lauter und auch darüber
wurde wohl gesprochen bei einer
Schaltkonferenz der USA mit
internationalen Verbündeten die in
diesen Minuten zu Ende geht mit dabei
waren unter anderem die G7-Staaten
Vertreter der EU und
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg für
Deutschland hat Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz teilgenommen er wird in wenigen
Minuten eine Pressekonferenz geben hier
sehen wir das Bild aus dem
Bundeskanzleramt mit dem G7 Logo der in
Deutschland hat ja seit 1 Januar auch
den Vorsitz der die hat die G7
Präsidentschaft inne seit dem
Januar diesen Jahres in wenigen Minuten
erwarten wir also Bundeskanzler Scholz
und Science Statement und das wird auch
deshalb mit so großem Interesse verfolgt
weil auch innenpolitisch der Druck auf
den Kanzler sehr stark gestiegen ist in
den letzten Tagen und Stunden was die
Frage angeht welche schweren Waffen in
die Ukraine geliefert werden können und
wann darüber sprechen wir in dieser
Sendung und jetzt auch direkt schon mit
unserer Korrespondentin in Berlin Nicole
Diekmann ist uns zugeschaltet Nicole wir
haben natürlich im Auge was im
Bundeskanzleramt passiert und wenn es
dort losgeht schalten wir dorthin bis
dahin nutzen wir die Gelegenheit mit dir
darüber zu sprechen was erwartest du von
dieser Pressekonferenz von Olaf Scholz
gleich
naja Stichwort was erwartest du die
Erwartungen sind hoch der Druck auf
Scholz ist relativ hoch es ist das eine
wenn die Oppositionsführerin die CDU
mittlerweile man muss fast sagen damit
rot eine eigenen Antrag einzubringen
zum Thema schwere Waffen an die Ukraine
liefern es ist das andere wenn auch aus
den Reihen der eigenen Ampelkoalition
vor allem natürlich aus der grünen
Partei und aus der FDP die SPD versucht
öffentlich nicht zu streiten massive
Kritik am Kanzler geübt wird erstens an
seiner Kommunikation und zweitens ich
zitiere wörtlich an seinem Zaudern so
hat es vergangene Woche Marie Agnes
schreibt Zimmermann gesagt
FDP-Politikerin und Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses die
Unzufriedenheit mit Scholz wächst eben
nicht nur innerhalb der Ampel auch nicht
bei der CDU sondern auch innerhalb der
Bevölkerung der Spiegel hat gerade als
Aufmacher eine Umfrage wonach zwei
Drittel der Befragten Scholz als führ
schwach bzw nicht führungsstark
bezeichnen und das ist für ein Kanzler
vor allem für einen Kanzler der noch
nicht lange im Amt ist nicht
zufriedenstellen dann kann er nicht
zufrieden sein und dem muss er sich
jetzt irgendwie entgegenstellen er muss
liefern er muss ich lache deshalb weil
er im doppelten Sinne liefern muss so
sehen ist jedenfalls einige er muss
heute irgendetwas Substanzielles sagen
zum Thema Waffenlieferungen an die
Ukraine ohne und das ist die Kunst dabei
den Eindruck zu erwecken getrieben zu
sein
Nicole ich sehe hier gerade und bei
Youtube schreibt ein User namens der
dickhoff der Dickkopf warum zögert
Scholz bzw die Bundesregierung nur Geld
schicken wird der Ukraine nicht helfen
ja das ist die große Frage die wir uns
alle stellen
es gibt Stimmen in der SPD da ist zum
einen die Russlandpolitik es gibt da
eben diejenigen in der SPD die mit
Russland versucht haben durch Annäherung
durch Dialog eine Partnerschaft am Leben
zu erhalten
man sagt mittlerweile das sagt ja auch
Frank Walter Steinmeier Bundespräsident
lange Zeit Außenminister damit ist man
gescheitert aber das gehört eben auch
zur Geschichte der SPD und das andere
ist eben die Frage des Pazifismus
schwere Waffen so hört man auch aus der
SPD sind eben etwas anderes als Geld zu
geben und deswegen wird vielleicht auch
das was Scholz gleich sagt vor den
Kameras womöglich eher eine Nachricht in
seine eigene Partei sein in die linke
der SPD als an alle restlichen
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
kannst du uns denn gerade noch mal auf
den Stand bringen über was denn
überhaupt diskutiert wird also welches
Geld welche Waffen welche Möglichkeiten
stehen denn überhaupt im Raum und zur
Diskussion
es gibt die Anfrage aus der Ukraine da
geht es um Panzer um den Marder und um
den Leopard 1 da gibt es einmal den
Argumentationsstrang der zu hören ist
derjenigen die sagen das können wir
nicht tun
weil an diesem Gerät geübt werden muss
das kann man den Ukrainern ich sage das
jetzt mal sehr legere nicht einfach in
die Hand drücken das Halten andere
wiederum darunter sind auch
Militärexperten und keine Politiker also
nicht nur Politiker sondern tatsächlich
auch Militärexperten die sagen das ist
vorgeschoben das Argument das stimmt
nicht so viel Hightech steckt zum
Beispiel in so einem Marder nicht drin
und
die Bundeswehr könnte zum Beispiel 20
Panzer aus ihren Beständen zur Verfügung
stellen und reinmetall Rüstungsindustrie
spielt ja eine wichtige Rolle könnte
binnen weniger Wochen die Bundeswehr
wiederum mit ersatzausstatten das heißt
da wäre jetzt keine eklatante Lücke das
ist das eine worüber geredet wird und
das andere ist jetzt kommt Achtung ein
sehr deutsch dort Ungetüm das kam am
Wochenende als eine Art ich würde sagen
Kompromissvorschlag die Aufstockung der
sogenannten ertüchtigungsinitiative das
ist ein Fonds bisher ein paar hundert
Millionen schwer damit seinen Länder
seit 2016 gibt es das finanziert werden
in ihrem militärischen Hab und Gut
dieser Fonds diese
ertüchtigungsinitiative soll aufgestockt
werden auf zwei Milliarden und
rund eine Milliarde davon soll an die
Ukraine gehen
das klingt jetzt erstmal gut das hat
aber einige Tücken im Detail denn
erstens braucht es dazu ein Haushalt da
ist die Frage wie schnell kann das gehen
da sagen die Gegner dieser Idee es geht
jetzt um Tage wir können jetzt nicht
noch warten bis dieser Haushalt erstmal
beschlossen ist und da gibt es
diejenigen die sagen damit macht sich
Deutschland einen schlanken Fuß nämlich
der Ukraine Geld in die Hand zu drücken
und quasi damit zu sagen kauft davon was
ihr wollt wo ihr wollt aber bitte nicht
bei uns auch darum gibt es im Moment
viel Streit auch wegen der offenen
Fragen was darf die Ukraine davon kaufen
wo darf sie damit kaufen was kann sie
davon kaufen und wie schnell kann sie
damit überhaupt irgendetwas kaufen
wir haben auch später in der Sendung den
ehemaligen Nato-General Rams der auch
noch mal was dazu sagen kann was du
gerade angesprochen hast mit was können
die Ukrainer überhaupt die jetzt
operieren und was hilft was hilft jetzt
wirklich und wie können auch viele
dieser Waffen überhaupt dahin kommen wo
sie gebraucht werden wir werfen
gemeinsam noch mal einen Blick ins
Bundeskanzleramt und sehen dass die
Kollegen so wie wir das auch tun
noch warten vielleicht können wir Ihnen
das Bild noch mal zeigen also gut es
gibt Spannenderes als Deutschlandfahnen
von der leeren Wand und wartende
Journalisten aber nicht damit sie das
Gefühl haben sie würden was verpassen
das hier also ist der Raum in dem gleich
die Pressekonferenz stattfindet noch
findet sie nicht statt und deshalb würde
ich sagen schauen wir uns gemeinsam an
die Kollegin Patricia Wiedemeyer hat mal
zusammengetragen was ist denn an
Forderungen gibt an Olaf Scholz und fast
noch mal die Debatte um die
Waffenlieferungen in die Ukraine
zusammen
die Rufe nach schwerem Gerät für die
Ukraine werden immer lauter der
Bundeskanzler handele zu langsam tue zu
wenig so der Vorwurf selbst die
zugesagte Aufstockung der finanziellen
Hilfen um eine Milliarde der Opposition
nicht genug sie wirft Olaf Scholz
führungsversagen vor
wir halten es für erforderlich das
schwere Waffen geliefert werden das ist
auch die Meinung vieler in der Koalition
nur der Kanzler äußert sich nicht und
ist auch nicht zu einer Entscheidung in
der Lage der Bundeskanzler die SPD unter
Druck sie verteidigen sich damit dass
man Tschechien genehmigt habe Panzer aus
NVA Beständen an die Ukraine zu geben
die Bundeswehr verfügt über keine
weiterhin frei verfügbaren Waffen die
abgegeben werden können deswegen muss
jetzt die Industrie und müssen wie
gesagt auch mögliche andere Lieferungen
möglich gemacht werden die
Bundesregierung ist dabei diese
Möglichkeiten auszuloten aber auch
Vertreter der Ampelkoalition die letzte
Woche in der Ukraine waren bleiben bei
ihrer Forderung nach schweren Waffen
bestärkt werden sie darin von
ExpertInnen meine Forderung ist erstmal
und mein Wunsch dass der Bundeskanzler
sich jetzt mal dafür ausspricht dass wir
grundsätzlich schwere Waffen liefern
Artillerie möglicherweise Panzer die
Zeit drängt der Krieg wartet nicht bis
wir uns sortiert haben die wenigsten
hätten erwartet dass die Ukraine so gut
widerstehen kann wie sie das gemacht hat
und da muss man ganz klar sagen das
waren auch die westlichen
Waffenlieferungen die Unionsparteien
drohen nun damit den Bundestag darüber
abstimmen zu lassen der CDU-Vorsitzende
März dazu heute auf Twitter der offen
ausgetragene Streit der Koalition
schadet dem Ansehen unseres Landes in
der ganzen Welt aber es gibt eine
Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag auch für
schwere Waffen an die Ukraine jenseits
von SPD AFD und Linkspartei
Geld statt schwerer Waffen ob das
Kanzleramt dabei bleibt offen in etwa
einer Stunde will sich der Kanzler nun
doch äußern dann soll es ein Statement
hier im Kanzleramt geben
und genau diese eine Stunde ist jetzt
vorbei es ist nämlich jetzt genau der
Zeitpunkt an dem wir dieses Statement
erwarten Nicole Diekmann ist wieder bei
uns Nicole ich sehe hier im Chat ein
Usernamen Zen estra Norm schreibt über
Youtube Scholz ist der Situation nicht
gewachsen und sollte zurücktreten
Harbeck sollte als Vize übernehmen der
hat wenigstens verstanden um was es hier
geht Nicole so wie ich das wahrgenommen
habe gibt es sehr laute Kritik an der
Politik von Olaf Scholz aber noch keine
Rücktrittsforderungen oder
nein und ich glaube wir müssen uns auch
immer mal vor Augen halten dass auch in
Zeiten von Social Media die
rücktrittsförderung gerne etwas
inflationär benutzt wird also das habe
ich tatsächlich noch von jemandem gehört
nicht mal aus der AFD wenn ich das
richtig in Erinnerung habe aber aus
keiner der anderen Parteien weder
Opposition noch ampelparteien also weit
sind wir noch lange nicht
gleichwohl erlebt man ja aber auch in
den sozialen Medien auf Twitter zum
Beispiel das großes Unverständnis
darüber herrscht auch international wenn
man sich die Berichte anguckt dass die
Deutschen zum Beispiel viel damit
beschäftigt sind den ukrainischen
Botschafter zu kritisieren dafür dass er
angeblich nicht Bitte und Danke sagt
während in der Ukraine Menschen sterben
und die deutschen keine politische
Entscheidung darüber treffen können wie
sie denn tatkräftig helfen sollen also
man merkt die Worte werden schärfer und
die Kritik wird in der Tat lauter
die Kritik wird lauter das ist keine
Frage du hast ihn gerade angesprochen
der ukrainische Botschafter hier in
Deutschland andere Melnik polarisiert ja
quasi sagt Kriegsbeginn weil er sehr und
diplomatisch Auftritt was er ja sehr
bewusst tut da sagen die einen das geht
so nicht er erweist der ganzen Sache
damit einen Bärendienst die anderen
sagen was soll der Mann denn anderes
machen
dann ganz befindet sich in einem
Angriffskrieg ist Opfer eines
Angriffskrieges er muss jetzt so
auftreten um immer wieder darauf
aufmerksam zu machen wie groß die Not
ist auch da gibt es auch das hast du ja
gerade erwähnt innerhalb der SPD
ein ich würde es mal vielstimmigen Korn
nennen das Zitat dass du eben genannt
hast bitte und danke sein die Wörter die
andere Melnik benutzen sollte das kommt
von Florian Post dazu muss man sagen der
Mann ist SPD
Politiker ist aber nicht mehr Mitglied
des Deutschen Bundestages und hat schon
vorher innerhalb seiner Partei für sehr
viel Ärger gesorgt das würde ich jetzt
mal ein bisschen unter ferner liefen
einordnen aber auch viel zu Präsidentin
des Bundestages Frau ösos hat über die
Osterfeiertage einen sehr kritischen
Tweet in Bezug auf den ukrainischen
Botschafter abgesetzt den sie inzwischen
gelöscht hat weil auch aus ihrer eigenen
Partei zum Beispiel in Form von Saskia
esken und lasking bei Kritik an dieser
Kritik kam und das durch ein Treffen der
beiden spd-chefs mit manik flankiert
wird also ja da gibt es viel Streit da
gibt es
sehr viel
böse da muss man den Social Media Faktor
abziehen und da muss man eben auch immer
einordnen wer äußert sich da aus der
wievielten Reihe einer Partei wem geht
es wirklich um Inhalte dem geht es um
Diskurs und wem geht es um
Aufmerksamkeit die er sonst zwar abends
nicht mehr erhalten würde
Nicole ich habe hier noch zwei drei
Kommentare die ich gerne Vorlesen würde
DB schreibt über Youtube die Ukraine
darf nicht verlieren und muss mit allen
Möglichkeiten Unterstützung erfahren das
Zögern besonders aus dem Kanzleramt
gefährdet den Frieden in ganz Europa
ähnlich äußert sich Simon C auch über
youtube ist es mittlerweile einfach
peinlich wie sehr Deutschland in wenigen
Wochen sein Image ramponiert hat wie in
Deutschland sollten nicht die Bremser
sein und Christoph K schreibt auch über
Youtube das ist schon längst nicht mehr
ein ukrainischer Krieg sondern an
europäischer Krieg ich halte es für
einen Fehler so zu tun als würde es uns
nichts angehen Putins Truppen gehören
zurückgedrängt
Nicole das ist in etwa auch das was
Marie agnesstrak Zimmermann ja auch
sagte du hast sie gerade auch schon
zitiert sie hat sich jetzt in der
Rheinischen Post geäußert und sagt wir
sollten uns nicht hinter
eskalationsszenarien verschanzen also
nicht aus Angst vor dem wie Putin
vielleicht reagieren könnte einfach am
besten nichts tun oder weniger tun sie
sagt putin ist sowieso unberechenbar für
uns wie wie verbreitet ist denn diese
Haltung in Berlin
ja klar das ist mittlerweile die
Argumentation derjenigen die sagen
schwere Waffen an die Ukraine die
Gegenposition ist eben die die große
Angst vor dem nato-bündnisfall das Putin
ein Dreh ein Kniff für sich findet
quasi nachzuweisen dass sich die
NATO-Staaten diesen Krieg einmischen ich
muss das immer in Anführungszeichen
setzen und dann quasi für sich die
Legitimation und darin sieht diesen
Krieg auszuweiten jetzt muss man eben
fragen
erstens wie berechenbar ist ein Mann der
einen solchen Angriffskrieg wie er ihn
gegen die Ukraine führt führt und zum
zweiten
Nicole bevor du den zweiten Punkt
ausführst lass uns kurz den Kanzler
Hören und Sehen er ist nämlich jetzt da
und wir erwarten seine Ausführungen wir
gehen ins Kanzleramt
meine Damen und Herren der russische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine ist heute
Nacht in eine neue Phase getreten
russland hat die erwartete Offensive im
Osten der Ukraine begonnen Städte und
dafür werden bombardiert 10.000
russische Soldaten versuchen das Land zu
erobern Putins armee greift in der
gesamten Ukraine Ziele mit Raketen an
seit fast zwei Monaten führt Russland
Krieg gegen die Ukraine schon jetzt sind
zehntausende Todesopfer zu beklagen
gehören immer wieder neue Berichte über
Kriegsverbrechen und das Leid der
Zivilbevölkerung nimmt weiter zu mehr
mehr als 3 Millionen Ukrainerin und
Ukrainer sind auf der Flucht vor dem
russischen Militär und finden Schutz und
Unterstützung in vielen Ländern in Polen
in Rumänien in Moldawien auch viele in
Deutschland ich bin den Bürgern und
Bürgern unseres Landes sehr dankbar
dafür dass sie die Solidarität mit der
Ukraine tragen und dass sie auch
Solidarität zeigen mit denjenigen die
hier zu uns kommen
die meisten von uns werden über die
Osterfeiertage über diesen Krieg
gesprochen haben das Leid der Ukraine
lässt niemanden kalt
wir spüren unendliche Trauer über die
Opfer und auch das muss gesagt werden
große Wut große Wut auf den russischen
Präsidenten und diesen sinnlosen Krieg
in der Situation ist es ganz ganz
wichtig dass wir Verbündete haben mit
denen wir uns eng abstimmen und darüber
beraten wie wir die Ukraine am besten
unterstützen können klar ist wir alle
werden die Ukraine weiter unterstützen
finanziell und auch militärisch
heute Nachmittag habe ich mit dem
amerikanischen dem Französischen und dem
polnischen Präsidenten mit den
Ministerpräsidenten von Kanada Italien
Rumänien und Großbritannien sowie den
eu-repräsentanten ausführlich in einer
Videoschalte über die Lage und unsere
gemeinsamen Reaktionen gesprochen
wir haben dabei klare Prinzipien über
die sind sich alle einig die Ukraine
bekommt weiterhin unsere volle
Solidarität und Unterstützung
als Staats- und Regierungschefs ist es
gleichzeitig unsere Pflicht eine
Ausweitung des Kriegs auf andere Länder
zu verhindern daher kann und wird die
NATO nicht direkt in den Krieg
Eingreifen dabei bleibt es darüber sind
wir uns alle einig unser Handeln wird
von diesen Prinzipien getragen
größtmögliche Unterstützung für die
Ukraine aber keine Beteiligung der NATO
an dem Krieg
das alles geschieht eng abgestimmt mit
dem Partnern hier in Europa und auf der
anderen Seite des Atlantiks
deutsche allein Gänge wären falsch
denn die Verbundenheit und
Geschlossenheit von uns als Partnern ist
die Stärke die wir haben der russische
Präsident Putin hat mit diesem
geschlossenen Handeln nicht gerechnet er
hat sich verkalkuliert unsere
Geschlossenheit sollte niemanden in
Frage stellen aus keinen Erwägung auch
keinen innenpolitischen denn das
schädigt nicht nur unser Land sondern
das stärkt den russischen Präsidenten
unsere Maßnahmen treffen Russland und
putinhart die Sanktionen zeigen eine
sehr sehr deutliche Wirkung
eigentlich war für Russland für dieses
Jahr ein kräftiges Wachstum vorhergesagt
nun rechnen Experten damit dass es um
mindestens achteinhalb Prozent
vielleicht mehr schrumpfen wird und dass
die Inflation sogar bei 25% liegen
könnte das ist ein Desaster für Russland
und eine direkte Folge des
angriffskriegs gegen die Ukraine
wir bereiten die Wirkung der Sanktionen
immer vor und schauen uns die jeweils an
und bereiten nächste Schritte vor auch
das gemeinsam und nicht allein in enger
Abstimmung mit den USA mit Frankreich
mit Italien und Großbritannien so wie
wir es vom ersten Tag des Krieges
angetan haben und auch weiterhin tun
werden
in diesem Sinne handelt die
Bundesregierung und handle auch ich
ich nehme meinen Amtseid sehr ernst dazu
zählt auch sich gegeneinander zu stellen
der das Völkerrecht mit Füßen tritt und
das eigene Bündnis so zu stärken das
Putin keinen Angriff wagt
direkt zu Beginn des Krieges haben wir
entschlossen gehandelt mit beispiellosen
Sanktionen und mit der Entscheidung
erstmals im größeren Umfang Waffen in
dieses Kriegsgebiet zu liefern viele in
Europa sind diesen unserem Schritt
gefolgt
angesichts des Angriffs auf die Ukraine
war das richtig und auch nötig Waffen zu
liefern damit sich die Ukraine gegen den
Krieg wehren kann der gegen sie geführt
wird und der klar gegen das Völkerrecht
verstößt
wir haben uns dabei stets davon leiten
lassen zu liefern was zügig umsetzbar
und schnell einsetzbar ist
alle unsere Lieferung fügen sich in das
ein was unsere engsten Verbündeten und
Freunde ihrerseits auf den Weg gebracht
haben unser gemeinsames Ziel das Ziel
von Dutzenden von Nationen die
mittlerweile die Ukraine unterstützen
mit finanzieller Hilfe und mit
militärischen Lieferungen ist es das
ukrainische Militär so zu ertüchtigen
das ist sich des russischen Angriffs
erwehren kann
anfangs haben wir die Ukraine mit Waffen
aus unserem eigenen Beständen beliefert
hier müssen wir inzwischen erkennen dass
die Möglichkeiten die wir haben an ihre
Grenzen stoßen
deshalb setzen wir auch ein
Sondervermögen auf damit unsere Armee
nach Jahren des Spans endlich gut
ausgestattet sein wird und investieren
massiv in die Fähigkeiten der Bundeswehr
das wird nicht von heute auf morgen
gehen aber die jetzige Situation ist ein
guter Anlass noch mal zu unterstreichen
wie wichtig das ist dass wir mehr tun
für unsere Bundeswehr und dass wir auch
dieses Sondervermögen fest im
Grundgesetz verankern
unsere Fähigkeit Deutschland und das
Gebiet unserer NATO Verbündeten gegen
einen russischen Angriff zu verteidigen
werden wir auch in dieser Situation
immer aufrechterhalten und deshalb haben
wir in einem zweiten Schritt ermöglicht
dass die Ukraine Militärgüter aus
industrieller Produktion in unserem
Ländern kaufen kann
unsere Lieferung fügen sich auch weiter
in das ein was unsere verängsten
Verbündeten und Freunde ihrerseits auf
den Weg gebracht haben und unser
gemeinsames Ziel ist es das ukrainische
Militär weiterhin so zu ertüchtigen dass
es sich auch weiterhin gegen den Angriff
zur Wehr setzen kann
wir haben die deutsche Rüstungsindustrie
gebeten und zu sagen welches Material
sie in nächsten Zeit liefern kann die
Ukraine hat sich nun von dieser Liste
eine Auswahl zu eigen gemacht und wir
stellen ihr das für den Kauf notwendige
Geld zur Verfügung darunter sind wie
bisher Waffen die Panzerabwehrwaffen
beinhalten
luftabwehrgeräte darunter gehören auch
andere Dinge wie Munition und auch das
was man im ateliergefecht einsetzen kann
zusätzlich sind wir bereit unsere
Nato-Partner die noch über Waffensysteme
verfügen die aus der russischen
Produktion stammen in der Ukraine selbst
genutzt werden und sofort einsetzbar
sind zu unterstützen das ist etwas was
wir mit vielen anderen zusammen so
machen die den gleichen Weg einschlagen
wie wir und dieser Weg ist auch richtig
denn sofortige schnelle Einsetzbarkeit
und Verfügbarkeit ist dafür wichtig
und natürlich gibt es jetzt
Waffensysteme die unsere Partner liefern
wie zum Beispiel Artillerie zusätzlich
die
voraussetzt dass es eine enge
Kooperation unter den Verbündeten gibt
auch da sind wir bereit das Notwendige
zu tun ob es sich nur um Entscheidungen
handelt die die USA treffen oder die
Niederlande die enge Zusammenarbeit in
diesen Fragen ist uns wichtig
es geht um diese militärischen Mittel
die wir zur Verfügung stellen werden wie
in der Vergangenheit und weiterhin mit
den verschiedenen Techniken die ich
beschrieben habe und den ganz massiven
Unterstützung die damit verbunden sind
aber insgesamt geht es auch darum die
Ukraine finanziell zu unterstützen
im Rahmen unser g7-präsidentschaft sind
wir bereit und aktiv dabei der
ukrainischen Regierung mit ihrer Bitte
zu helfen dass die Finanzhilfen auch in
entsprechenden Umfang zu Verfügung
gestellt werden sie wissen es geht um
insgesamt 50 Milliarden Euro eine
erheblicher Teil ist durch Zusagen
bereits gedeckt aber es fehlt noch etwas
und wir betrachten es als unsere Aufgabe
in der g7-präsidentschaft das jetzt
möglich zu machen
vielleicht zum Schluss diese Worte ganz
deutlich der Überfall Russlands auf die
Ukraine bleibt ein eklatanter Bruch des
Völkerrechts das Tausendfache Töten von
Zivilisten wie wir es gesehen haben ist
ein Kriegsverbrechen für das der
russische Präsident die Verantwortung
trägt
einen diktatfrieden wir Putin wohl
vorschwebt ist
nicht akzeptabel die unverletzbarkeit
der Grenzen und die territoriale
Integrität von Staaten bleibt das
grundlegende Prinzip der europäischen
sicherheitsordnung das ist ein Verträgen
alles festgelegt die Russland auch schon
mal unterschrieben hat
und deshalb auch hier noch mal das klare
Signal an der russischen Präsidenten
stoppen Sie den Beschuss der
ukrainischen Städte
machen sie ja sofort einen
Waffenstillstand möglich ziehen sie ihre
Soldaten aus der Ukraine ab und führen
sie ernsthafte Verhandlungen mit der
Ukraine stoppen Sie diesen schrecklichen
Krieg
gemeinsam mit unseren Partnern der unter
NATO sind wir uns völlig einig Russland
darf diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen das
internationale Recht muss siegen und wir
werden die Ukraine weiter aktiv
unterstützen
Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben sehr viel
überarbeitsteilung geredet in der Gruppe
mit den Partnern mit denen sie
gesprochen haben schließen sie aus das
deutsche Leopard Kampfpanzer in der
Schlacht um Donbass mitkämpfen würden
also gegen russische Kampfer Kampfpanzer
möglicherweise antreten oder ist das
eine Möglichkeit und würde Deutschland
damit zur Kriegspartei werden danke
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage die mir eine
Gelegenheit gibt nach der ich schon seit
einiger Zeit suche schauen Sie sich doch
mal um was andere so tun die mit uns eng
verbündet sind zum Beispiel unsere
Freunde in den G7 die USA Kanada
Großbritannien Frankreich Italien
und was die liefern die sind mit ihren
Militärs zu ähnlichen Schlussfolgerungen
gekommen was solches Gerät betrifft geht
es um sofort verfügbare
einsatzsysteme die vor allem dann
nutzbar gemacht werden können wenn es
welche sind die in der Ukraine schon
eingesetzt werden und deshalb ist es so
dass es kein Zufall ist dass alle zu dem
gleichen Schluss gekommen sind dass den
meisten Sinn macht wenn zum Beispiel
solche Systeme die bei den
osteuropäischen NATO-Partnern noch
vorhanden wird sind von dort aus
eingesetzt werden und wir denen dann
ermöglichen dass ihre eigene Sicherheit
für die Zukunft gewährleistet bleibt
also der Blick in die Welt hilft
manchmal weiter in diesem Fall führt er
zu der Erkenntnis diejenigen die in
einer vergleichbaren Ausgangslage sind
wie Deutschland handeln so wie wir
Scholz und Nicole Dieckmann unsere
Korrespondentin in Berlin ist wieder mit
dabei für die Analyse Nicole bevor wir
das gleich aufdröseln möchte ich gerade
das Aufgreifen was Olaf Scholz gesagt
hat nämlich den Blick in die Welt werfen
dann tun wir das doch mal und stellen
fest dass die Niederlände Niederlande
heute angekündigt haben schwere Waffen
wie unter anderem Panzerfahrzeuge in die
Ukraine zu schicken und weiter zu prüfen
ob die Lieferung von zusätzlichem
schweren Material sinnvoll und möglich
ist und es gibt ja Stimmen die sagen
hier stehen Marder auf dem Parkplatz von
Rheinmetall die können die Ukraine
bedienen die müssen einfach nur dahin
gebracht werden also ganz so wie Olaf
Scholz das gerade dargestellt hat müssen
wir hier ein bisschen zurecht rücken ist
ist die Welt ja nicht oder siehst du das
anders und um die Frage anzuschließen
die große Frage nach schweren Waffen hat
er jetzt so klar nicht mit einem Ja
beantwortet sondern eher den Status Quo
beschrieben und das würde ich jetzt
nicht als den Befreiungsschlag
interpretieren den viele sich gewünscht
hätten was die Unterstützung der Ukraine
angeht
sehe ich genauso wie du Christina ich
bin gestolpert auf die Einleitung seiner
Antwort auf die Frage eines Journalisten
die wir gerade noch gehört haben da sagt
er danke für die Frage es gibt mir die
Gelegenheit etwas zu sagen die
Gelegenheit nach der ich schon seit
langer Zeit suche also mir erschließt
sich nicht so genau warum ein
Bundeskanzler
der
unter Druck steht und von dem
tatsächlich gefordert wird auch aus den
eigenen Reihen sich jetzt endlich mal
klar zu äußern da noch lange nach einer
Gelegenheit suchen muss und warum er du
hast es gerade schon gesagt diese
Gelegenheit dann auch nicht nutzt um
eine klare Aussage zu tätigen denn die
Frage war ja klar werden Leopard 1
Panzer zum Beispiel wenn ich das noch
richtig in Erinnerung habe werden
Leopard Panzer an die Ukraine zum
Beispiel geliefert er hat es offen
gelassen das bedeutet er wollte nicht
klar sagen nein werden sie nicht und hat
mit dem Verweis auf
andere Länder quasi ein Ausweichmanöver
gefahren wenn man mal in diesem Bild
sein will in dieser Sprache die wir ja
im Moment leider alle benutzen müssen
und versucht sich das hat er ja die
ganzen ich habe es gestoppt 10 Minuten
und 27 Sekunden die er zuvor geredet hat
sich so ein bisschen zurückzuziehen
quasi das klingt jetzt sehr martialisch
aber wir sind ja in diesen Zeiten
Deutschland ein bisschen aus der
Schusslinie zu nehmen sich selber auch
er hat auch einmal von ich selber
gesprochen die Kritik fokussiert sich ja
auf ihn klar er ist der Regierungschef
in dem er nämlich sagt wir sind Teil
eines großen Bündnisses mit Partnern
dieses Bündnisses mehrere Bündnisse NATO
EU G7 mit denen stehe ich in einen
Kontakt die machen es auch nicht anders
als wir das war heute der Versuch zu
sagen so wie wir es machen ist es
richtig er hat ein paar Gründe genannt
und das Hauptargument war die anderen
machen es ja auch so
Nicole Diekmann ich glaube wir können
zusammenfassen diese Diskussion wird
unvermindert weitergehen vielen Dank
dass du bei uns im Stream warst vielen
dank dir fürs dabei sein und bis zum
nächsten Mal gerne tschüss und wir
werfen den Blick in die Ukraine dort wo
heute wie schon angesprochen die
Großoffensive der russischen Armee im
Süden und Osten begonnen hat der
Angriffskrieg der Russen in der Ukraine
ist in eine neue Phase getreten Volker
Duschek fast zusammen
der russische Angriff auf luhans und
Donezk ist am ersten Tag ein Krieg fast
ohne Bilder das russische
Staatsfernsehen veröffentlicht am Morgen
nur diese Aufnahmen von Kampfflugzeugen
von wann sie sind bleibt offen
1.260 Ziele sollen in der Nacht in der
Ukraine beschossen worden sein so ein
Sprecher des Verteidigungsministeriums
eine offizielle Bestätigung für den
Großangriff bis dato nur aus der Ukraine
wir stellen fest dass die russischen
Truppen den Kampf um den Don Bass
begonnen haben den sie seit einer langen
Zeit vorbereiten die neue Frontlinie ist
gewaltig 480 Kilometer von haarklift bis
mariopol offenbar sind die Russen nur an
wenigen Stellen durchgebrochen sagen
ukrainische Quellen das
Verteidigungsministerium in Moskau hat
hunderten Soldaten die sich im Werk
asafsstal verschanzt haben ein neues
Ultimatum gestellt bis zum Nachmittag
sollten Sie das 11 Quadratkilometer
große Gelände verlassen ohne Waffen dann
bleiben sie am Leben sagt der Kreml
der Krieg tarnt sich hinter einer
schönfärberischen Sprache Moskau spricht
von humanitären corridoren für die die
aufgeben die Skepsis unter denen die
sich verschanzt haben ist groß und
kriegt Nahrung durch bilder wie diese
aus dem zweiten geräumten Stahlwerk in
Mario Paul überall tote dutzende
Zivilisten und Soldaten Bilder des
Grauens
der russische Verteidigungsminister
wirft dem Westen vor mit seinen weiteren
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine den
Krieg absichtlich in die Länge zu ziehen
die USA und die von ihnen kontrollierten
westlichen Länder tun alles um die
militärische spezial-operation zu
verzögern der wachsende Umfang
ausländischer Waffenlieferung zeigt ihre
Absicht das kiefer-regime zum Kampf bis
zum letzten Ukrainer zu provozieren
die Großoffensive hat begonnen Experten
im Westen gehen davon aus dass der Kreml
dafür bis zu 10.000 weitere Soldaten in
die Ukraine gebracht hat
und wir schalten zu Dominik leßmeister
unserem Korrespondenten in Kiew Dominik
welche Berichte hören sie aus dem Süden
und Osten der Ukraine
ja das wird dort heftig gekämpft den
ganzen Tag schon diese Offensive hat ja
quasi in der Nacht begonnen mit
Luftschlägen dann Artilleriebeschuss
zusätzlich natürlich an verschiedenen
Orten in der Ostukraine auch im Süden
und im Südosten des Landes hier in Kiew
was die Nacht relativ ruhig das ist war
die letzten Tage nicht so da hat es mehr
Angriffe auch in Kiew gegeben aber diese
Kämpfe sind werden mit einer
Deutlichkeit und Heftigkeit geführt
jetzt in der Ostukraine die russischen
Truppen versuchen auch vorzustoßen
scheinen da wohl auch schon kleinere
Erfolge zu erzielen aber die
ukrainischen Verteidiger wehren sich und
wollen natürlich
die russischen Angriffstruppen irgendwie
aufhalten
was können sie uns konkret über die Lage
in Mario Paul berichten wir haben ja
gerade den Beitrag schon gesehen mit
schwer zu ertragenden Bildern was welche
Meldungen erreichen Sie aus dieser immer
noch schwer umkämpften Stadt
ja das ist letztendlich eigentlich diese
Kämpfe in Mario Paul weitergehen also
wir haben ja das Angebot jetzt auch
wieder der russischen Seite dass die
Ukraine in diesem Stahlwerk aufgeben mit
der Zusicherung des freien Geleits aber
die Ukraine lehnt das bisher ab auf
diesem Gelände der Stahlwerks befinden
sich auch Zivilisten das muss man sich
so vorstellen das ist 11
Quadratkilometer groß das ist ein
riesengelände schwer zugänglich auch und
die russische Luftwaffe hat die Nacht
wiederum mit langstreckenbombern dieses
Gelände bombardiert die Russen russische
Verteidigungsministerium versucht
natürlich jetzt mit Kräften das zu
stürmen wir hören aber aus Mario Pohl
Berichte über Straßenkämpfe über mehr
Haustür Haus an Haus kämpfen kann man
sagen und da wird weiterhin heftig
gekämpft und da sieht es nicht danach
aus als würde die würden die russischen
Truppen diese Stadt erobern
hier gibt es noch eine Frage von
Fridolin über Youtube man hört immer
wieder auch von russischen Angriffen auf
Don jetzt auch die letzten Wochen schon
steht die Stadt nicht schon seit 2014
unter Kontrolle pro russischer Rebellen
können Sie das beantworten wie es diese
Situation in den Gebieten und in der Tat
herrscht dort ja schon seit Jahren Krieg
ja wir sprechen ja immer auch immer von
der Region jetzt ist das richtig dass
die Stadt von den Separatisten quasi
beherrscht wird aber in den angrenzenden
Gebieten
ist ja die Ukraine und natürlich findet
ihr einen Krieg statt das heißt es ist
natürlich auch nicht auszuschließen dass
die Ukraine und das wird sie sicher auch
tun auf Separatisten Gebiet feuert das
ist an der Stelle ein Krieg wo beide
Seiten natürlich auch Waffen einsetzen
auf beiden Seiten Menschenleben sterben
aber an der Stelle glaube ich muss man
auch sehen dass die russische Seite
dieses Land die Ukraine auch angegriffen
hat
Dominik gibt es weitere Berichte über
Angriffe im Rest der Ukraine
also ich hatte eben schon gesagt Kiew
ist ja bisher relativ ruhig auch in der
Nacht gewesen heute jetzt den ganzen Tag
auch wir haben halt Berichte vor allen
Dingen im Südosten im Süden und im Osten
des Landes also auch Nikolai saporicia
also das sind Städte die quasi direkt
eine Nähe von Mario Pohl sind die aber
noch in Hand der ukrainischen Verbände
und Truppen sind auch in die nipro gab
es Angriffe auch das eine Stadt die
Großstadt die weiterhin natürlich auch
in ukrainischer Hand ist das hat damit
zu tun dass natürlich die die russischen
luftwaffenkräfte versuchen
Nachschubwege zu treffen und auch die
Ukraine in der Gänze natürlich auch
anzugreifen wir hatten ja diese diese
Angriffe in Lemberg gestern das war
jetzt heute nicht der Fall aber damit
muss man rechnen auch hier in Kiew ist
nicht ausgeschlossen dass es wieder zu
Angriffen kommt
Dominik eine letzte Frage hier schreibt
Mikey Mike auch über Youtube Scholz
redet von Missachtung von
Menschenrechten aber putin will die
Ukraine auslöschen ich glaube Scholz
erfasst die Tragweite der Situation noch
gar nicht du hast auch gerade verfolgt
was der Kanzler hier gesagt hat zu neuen
Waffenlieferungen in die Ukraine und
gerade was schwere Waffen angeht hat er
sich da sehr zurückhaltend und bis
eigentlich gar nicht geäußert Dominik
wie reagieren die Menschen in der
Ukraine was erwarten sie gerade von
Deutschland
also wir haben jetzt hier noch keine
offizielle Reaktion der Ukraine aber wir
wissen ja dass Präsident silensky
eigentlich vehements und jeden Tag
schwere Waffen fordert für die Ukraine
und das sind Panzer und das sind
Haubitzen das sind Waffen die die
Ukraine auch brauchen um diesen Angriff
abzuwehren ich vermute mal dass wir auch
in den nächsten Stunden da eine Reaktion
bekommen aber ich denke dass das
weiterhin eine Enttäuschung ist der
Ukraine weil man hat sich sicher auch
erhofft dass Deutschland ein klareren
Schritt geht wie auch die Niederlande
die jetzt bereit sind schwere Waffen zu
liefern
vielen Dank Dominik Lessmeister nach
Kiew für diese Einschätzungen und wir
setzen das Gespräch hier im Studio fort
mit einem der sehr genau die Lage
verfolgt auch in der Ukraine im Osten
der Ukraine zugeschaltet ist und der
ehemalige Nato-General Egon Rams schönen
guten Abend harams wenn sie verfolgen
wenn sie verfolgen was sie hören aus dem
aus dem der Taktik der Russen die jetzt
ihre Angriffe in den Süden und Osten der
Ukraine verlagert haben welche
Erkenntnisse haben sie da heute an
diesem ersten Tag
und zunächst einmal möchte ich
feststellen dass auch der Außenminister
der russische Außenminister lavroff
heute von einer neuen Phase der
sonderoperation gesprochen hat das heißt
die Tatsache dass der Angriff begonnen
hat auch von beiden Seiten offiziell
bestätigt muss nicht mehr in Zweifel
gezogen werden die russische Seite hat
aus dem Norden der Ukraine bzw aus dem
aus Belarus und Teilen Russlands Kräfte
in großer Stärke verlegt in den Osten um
im Osten einen neuen Angriff anzusetzen
ich formuliere das absichtlich so weil
das ja weder vorher in Kiew im Raum Kiew
noch im Osten vorangekommen ist
wenn meine Kenntnisse richtig sind mit
aller Vorsicht sind Verstärkungskräfte
dazu rangezogen worden in aller größten
Ordnung von 20 bis 30.000 Soldaten da
gibt es unterschiedliche Angaben von
daher bitte dort vorsichtig und man
greift offensichtlich jetzt auf der
gesamten Breite 400 bis 480 Kilometer
zwischen
den Pool im weitesten Sinne an um auf
den Beitrag von der listmeister noch mal
zurückzukommen
bisher war es so dass von den
Separatisten Gebieten noch Hanske etwa
ein Drittel bis die Hälfte in den Händen
der Separatisten gewesen ist und jetzt
versucht man halt eben die anderen Teile
dieser beiden Regionen oder wenn man so
will der von Putin anerkannten
Volksrepubliken entsprechend aus
russischer Sicht Anführungszeichen zu
befreien Anführungszeichen werden
natürlich die Ukraine an Interesse daran
hat die Territorium soweit wie möglich
zu verteidigen zu den zu den Angriffen
beispielsweise auf Kiew gestern mit den
Raketen oder auch auf wiff das sehe ich
so dass man deutliche Signale von Seiten
der russischen Seite setzen will an die
ukanische Zivilbevölkerung wir haben das
unter Kontrolle wir sind in der Lage
euch jederzeit an jeder Stelle
anzugreifen und auf diese Art und Weise
ich glaube das mal einen Art
bevölkerungsterrorismus auszuüben wieder
Angriff in dem Ostteil Vorankommen wird
wie die Verteidigung aufgebaut ist und
ob sie erfolgreich sein wird wird sich
so glaube ich schon in den nächsten
Tagen also relativ bald zeigen man kann
glaube ich davon ausgehen wenn die
russische Streitkräfte keine großen
Gelände Gewinne machen das ist ähnlich
erfolgreich sein wird wie vorher im
Norden von Kiew also von aus russischer
Sicht nicht erfolgreich können Sie noch
mal also das können sie uns bestimmt
gleich erklären verbunden aber auch mit
der Frage was bedeutet das alles was Sie
gerade genannt haben für die ukrainische
Armee
also die ukrainische die ukrainische
Armee befindet sich im Prinzip in einem
verteidigungsgefecht im weitesten Sinne
wobei sie dabei die ukrainische
Streitkräfte ich sage das mal
materialmäßig und ausrüstungsmäßig den
russischen Streitkräften unterliegen
sind aber diese Unterlegenheit durch
eine ungeheuer hohe Kampfmoral und einen
guten Kampf Willen zum Teil wettmachen
von daher darum sage ich es wird sie in
den nächsten Tagen zeigen wie das
weitergeht wo die Ukraine darauf
aufpassen muss das ist dass diese
Verstärkungskräfte beispielsweise von
von jakev aus oder auch von Mario Poll
aus ein Zangen Angriff durchführen
könnten der dann möglicherweise Teil der
ukrainische Streitkräfte einschließt und
das wäre dann eine fatale Situation dann
sind wir bei der Meinung nach
Waffenlieferungen die wir ja auch gerade
im Zentrum der Äußerung von Olaf Scholz
gesehen und gehört haben wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe dann ist die
ukrainische Armee quasi dazu gezwungen
eine Art Guerillakrieg zu führen weil
sie eine offene Feldschlacht gegen die
russische Armee gar nicht bestehen
könnte weil sie personell und auch was
die Ausrüstung angeht unterlegen ist
wenn ich da falsch liege dann
korrigieren Sie mich bitte insofern wie
wichtig ist es dass die ukrainische
Armee jetzt schwere Waffen bekommt und
Waffen die sie jetzt einsetzen kann und
wie wichtig ist dass da westliche
internationale Partner reagieren
also mit der offenen Feldschlacht bin
ich zunächst noch mal etwas vorsichtig
und zwar aus dem Grunde vorsichtig weil
auch dieses Gelände von Osten Richtung
hier von der Richtung Westen der Ukraine
nicht unbedingt das Panzer günstigste
Gelände ist das heißt auch hier der
Boden ist doch sehr feucht der ich sag
mal schlammig auch hier wird es keine so
großen Raum greifenden auf Panzer
Überlegenheit beruhen Angriffe der
russischen Kräfte gehen
wir sind auch noch nicht beim gerillia
Krieg sondern die Ukraine führt eine
zusammenhängende Verteidigung in diesem
Bereich durch die entsprechenden
ordnungsgemäß geführt wird gerillia
Krieg würde es erst dann werden wenn die
Soldaten und die Einheiten auf sich
alleine gestellt werden und dann
praktisch ich sage das mal im Nahkampf
russische Panzer russische
Schützenpanzer russische
arteriegeschütze vernichten müssten im
Prinzip mit nahbekämpfungsmittel wie
Minen und dergleichen mehr so weit sind
wir bei weitem noch nicht sondern die
Verteidigung hängt zusammen das heißt
aber wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
entschuldigung wenn ich da einhake dann
braucht die Ukraine gar keine Panzer
weil sie sie im Moment im Süden und
Osten genauso wenig einsetzen kann wie
die Russen oder ist auch das eine
falsche Annahme also
Panzer schwere Waffen
batteriegeschütze werden hilfreich oder
wären vielleicht hilfreich gewesen von
daher hätten entsprechenden
Entscheidungen für vier oder fünf Wochen
fallen müssen mit Blick auf den Kampf
und mariopool das ist erstmal eine ganz
sachliche Feststellung dort haben wir
ich formuliere das mal so nicht nur die
Ukraine sondern auch die ukrainischen
Soldaten in der Stadt mariopol im
Prinzip alleine gelassen und ich möchte
diese Gelegenheit nutzen um noch mal auf
einen Punkt in aller Deutlichkeit
hinzuweisen die Ukraine verteidigt
zurzeit die Freiheit Europas in der
Ukraine und ich glaube zu Europa gehört
auch Deutschland von daher wäre auch
deutsche Unterstützung nach meiner
Auffassung entsprechend angebracht
nochmal zurückzukommen auf die andere
Sache man kann mit Panzern und
Schützenpanzern angriffsgefechte führen
dann muss man sich bewegen man kann
verteidigungsgefechte führen die werden
etwas stationärer auch nicht nur
stationär durchgeführt und auch diese
verteidigungsgefechte kann man dann
entsprechend mit Panzerung
Schützenpanzer machen und diese schweren
Waffen Fehlen der Ukraine gerade mit
Blick auf das Kräfteverhältnis zu den
russischen Streitkräften von daher jeder
Panzer jeder Schützenpanzer jedes
ateliergeschütz jeder Raketenwerfer in
die Ukraine zusätzlich bekommt hilft
letztendlich diesen Kampf um die
Freiheit der Ukraine und damit auch für
Europa für die Ukraine besser zu
gestalten es gibt Gegner dieser
Panzerlieferungen in die Ukraine die zum
Beispiel sagen bis die da sind im
Südosten der Ukraine sind die Ketten
schon so abgefahren dass man sie gar
nicht mehr benutzen kann man kriegt sie
dort gar nicht hin weil sie über
Schienenwege transportiert werden
müssten die dann wiederum von den Russen
angegriffen werden könnten und außerdem
brauchen solche Panzer viele Ersatzteile
die man dann gar nicht vor Ort zur
Verfügung hat sie haben selbst
Maschinenbau studiert mit der
Spezialisierung unter anderem auf
Panzerbau was können sie denn zu diesen
Argumenten sagen diese Argumente sind
natürlich zunächst einmal richtig also
sie können nicht ein paar Kampfpanzer
oder ein Schützenpanzer nackt dorthin
liefern ohne Ersatzteile ohne Munition
und ohne die entsprechende logistische
Abstützung das heißt da muss
entsprechend für gesorgt werden nur wenn
ich diese Bedenken immer äußern diese
Bedenken wir eine Monstranz zu mir Herd
vor mir härterage dann passiert
überhaupt nichts
die Amerikaner haben nach meinem
Kenntnisstand in den letzten Tagen
Haubitzen beispielsweise geliefert mit
einer entsprechenden hohen Anzahl an
Munition und wenn das die Amerikaner
können und wenn die Amerikaner auch in
der Lage sind ukrainische Soldaten
relativ kurzfristig an diesem Geräten
auszubilden dann würde ich aus meiner
Sicht ja sagen dann lassen wir uns mal
kreativ an dieses Thema rangehen und
wollen wir mal sehen wie mit der Hilfe
der Industrie mit möglicherweise noch
bevorrater Munition der gleichen mehr
eine ähnliche Hilfe mit einem ähnlichen
Wert dort leisten können im Augenblick
habe ich den Eindruck der kann falsch
sein dass wir im Augenblick im Prinzip
immer nur locken und jetzt versuchen mit
der einen Milliarde die für diese Hilfe
an die Ukraine gegeben werden soll das
Problem durch die Ukraine lösen zu
lassen und uns selber relativ weit
zurückhaltend sie haben gerade den
Bundeskanzler gehört der hat mit dem
Verweis auf internationale Partner
gesagt wir machen auch nur das was die
anderen auch tun würden sie haben jetzt
gerade ein Beispiel genannt die
Niederlande sind ein anderes die auch
heute sich bereit erklärt haben schwere
Panzer wer schwere Waffen zu liefern wie
beurteilen Sie die Haltung von Olaf
Scholz in der aktuellen Frage der
Waffenlieferungen ich versuche solche
Dinge immer ein bisschen im Ganzen zu
betrachten wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere und ich glaube ich erinnere
mich richtig und haben die Niederlande
auch mit der Lieferung von Panzerfäusten
aus deutscher Herstellung angefangen
bevor wir uns selber entschieden haben
Panzerfäuste zu liefern wir haben auch
Witzen aus NVA Beständen über Finnland
dann von den Ästen an die Ukraine
geliefert wir mussten weil auch in
fahrbestände die Zustimmung geben für
die Lieferung von Panzern durch die
durch die Tschechische Republik und von
daher muss man feststellen die Aussage
die ich vorhin gehört habe wir verhalten
uns genauso wie die anderen
fällt mir im Augenblick ein bisschen
schwer sie zu verinnerlichen denn ich
sehe das mit etwas unterschiedlicher
Brille ich bin der Auffassung wir
könnten mehr tun wir sollten dieses auch
tun und ich bin auch überrascht jetzt
werde ich ein bisschen politisch steht
mir vielleicht nicht zu das innerhalb
der Koalition die beiden
Koalitionspartner FDP und Grüne mit sehr
lauter Stimme nach diesen
Waffenlieferungen
verlangen und das von der anderen Seite
von Seiten der Sozialdemokratischen
Partei dort im Prinzip relativ wenig
erfolgt ich muss allerdings auch dazu
sagen dass der Antrag in die CDU möglich
aber cdu/csu-fraktion möglicherweise
nächste Woche stellen wird
wahrscheinlich keine Aussicht auf Erfolg
hat aus dem Grunde relativ die Regierung
geschlossen abgelehnt werden wird das
heißt er kriegt keine Mehrheit auch wenn
in der Sache möglicherweise berechtigt
ist
ich möchte gerne versuchen ein zwei User
innen Fragen unterzubringen Lauren
parteimüller über Youtube fragt wenn der
Krieg länger dauert ist es dann
wahrscheinlich dass die USA und die
nato-ukraine auf westlicher Technologie
ausbilden und dann liefern
also ich halte das für möglich ist eine
Frage der Zeit wobei ich noch mal
wiederhole wir haben bereits Zeit
verloren diese Entscheidung hätten vor
vier oder fünf Wochen bereits fallen
können sind aber nicht gefallen ich
würde mal die Rede zur Zeiten wenn du
das Kanzlers als einen bestimmten Punkt
nehmen wo man dann auch über die Folge
Fragen hätte entsprechend entscheiden
können und da haben wir Zeit verloren
aber
den Schutzschild den manche Leute
aufbauen dass man halbes Jahr oder
länger braucht um einen Panzersoldaten
oder schützenpanzersoldaten auszubilden
den halte ich für etwas überzogen
sia harmo fragt auch über Youtube wie
realistisch ist es das Russland den
Krieg verliert wir reden immer noch von
einer Militärmacht ich sehe die
Waffenlieferungen kritisch
also die Prognose zu machen ob Russland
den Krieg verliert ist sicherlich zum
heutigen Zeitpunkt an etwas gesagt
gespielt aber ich möchte darauf
hinweisen dass gegenüber den
strategischen Zielen die der Präsident
Putina am Anfang dieses Krieges sprich
im Februar verkündet hat zurzeit von
diesen strategischen Zielen durchaus
Abstriche gemacht werden und die Absicht
der russischen Seite ist es sicherlich
nicht gewesen im Norden Richtung Kiew im
Osten und im Süden zeitgleich überall
anzugreifen um sich dann nach einer
Dauer von etwa vier bis fünf Wochen aus
dem Norden spricht von Kiew fährt
zurückzuziehen die Kräfte um zu
probieren und im Osten neu anzusetzen
von daher ist der militärische Plan der
russischen Seite bisher nicht in
Erfüllung gegangen und ich sage mit
meinen Worten wenn die Ukraine in der
Art und Weise weiter kämpft die
Kampfmoral in der Art und Weise weiter
zeigt dann wird auch jetzt die Eroberung
die beabsichtigte Eroberung der beiden
Regionen Johannes und Don jetzt
werden für die russische Seite
eine letzte Frage bevor ich einen einen
Kommentar muss ich noch unterbringen
vorher hier bedankt sich nämlich jemand
bei Ihnen Oliver Stapel schreibt endlich
spricht harams Klartext danke das muss
ich an dieser Stelle weitergeben und wie
gesagt eine letzte
Zuschauerfrage gut Tanks fragt über
Youtube Herr Rams wieso greift man nicht
Putin mit einer Drohne an und hofft
darauf dass danach Ruhe ist die Frage
nach dem Tyrannenmord ist sehr sehr alt
und sie wird aber in dieser in diesem
Konflikt auch immer wieder
gestellt was glauben Sie selbst wenn es
Putin nicht mehr gäbe in diesem Szenario
würde dann dieser Krieg beendet sein
also ich glaube dass nicht ich glaube
das aus dem Grunde nicht weil a
rechtliche Seite eine ein solcher
Angriff auf Putin sei es mit einer
Drohne sei es mit irgendwelchen anderen
Mitteln rechtlich auch kein Bestand
hätte wobei man natürlich die Gegenfrage
dann sofort stellen muss an welches
Recht hält sich der Präsident Putin und
trotzdem gehöre ich zu denen die ich
sage das mal mit Blick auf Rechtsstaat
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Anhalten von
Verträgen Einhalten von Verträgen dieses
relativ hoch bewerten warum glaube ich
nicht dass wenn Putin tatsächlich ich
sag mal durch einen Umsturz von innen
oder durch einen Angriff von außen
getötet werden sollte dass die Sache zu
Ende ist wenn sie sich den Leiter seines
nationalen Sicherheitsrates anhören
nämlich den ehemaligen Präsidenten und
Ministerpräsidenten mit wettjew dann
sind zum Teil die Töne von medvities
sind schärfer noch als die vom Putin von
daher es gibt eine Führungsriege in
Russland die möglicherweise diesen Krieg
dann auch weiterführen würde wenn sich
in der Führung in dem russ deutliche
Veränderungen ergeben wird
sagt der ehemalige Nato-General Egon
Rams vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns in
unserer Sendung waren und so viele
Fragen beantwortet haben vielen Dank und
wahrscheinlich sehen wir uns sehr bald
an dieser Stelle wieder Dankeschön ihnen
heraus
und ich bedanke mich natürlich auch im
Namen des Teams bei ihnen allen zu Hause
fürs mitkommentieren und Fragen stellen
für alle Fans des linearen Fernsehens
sei hier auf die 19 Uhr heute verwiesen
die jetzt in wenigen Minuten beginnt und
danach gibt es ein ZDF Spezial zum
Angriffskrieg der Russen nun im Süden
und Osten der Ukraine sie bleiben
informiert hier beim ZDF und wir freuen
uns wenn Sie beim nächsten Mal wieder
hier dabei sind Tschüss bis dann